MARC-ANDRE FLEURY COMES TO WALK.
ANOTHER GREAT CHANCE.
AND A GOAL ON THE REBOUND.ONE-T.
WALKER TOIN RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: THERE'S A GOAL FOR
>> Ray: THIS PUCK IS GOING TO
BOUNCE AROUND ON THE FAILSOFF.
AND ZUCCCC
GREAT TO SEE JOE.
WELCOME HIM OUT TO STARTS THE R
WITH1, AGAINST PITTSBURGH.
NASHVILLE, A WINNER OVER
CHICAGO.
THEY ARE STILL IN PLAYOFF
POSITION IN THE WEST.
TWO BIG POINTS OT.
IN FIVE SECONDS, WILL GET
MIDDLETON BACK.
CROSS-ICE PASS AND A
FREE PUCK FOR O'REILLY.
SAAD TO THE NET.
SAAD DOWN LOW, SCORES.
AND JOST DOESN'T REACT QUICK
ENOUGH KILLING
HAS THE POINT RECORD, THAT WAS
HELD BY GABORIK.
GOLIGOSKI IN.
AND A TIP-IN
GETS HIS STICK ON THE  GOIT IT
FIALA.
THE ONE-TIMER AND
BACK IN THE AMERICAN LEAGUE, IN
THE NASHVILLE ORGANIZATION.
THO
EMPTY POINT.
HE WANTS TO GET 27 FOR BUCHNEVI.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT EVERYBODY IN
THEE
CROSS-ICE FOR BOLDY.
EIGHT SECONDS ON THE ST. LOUIS
PENALTY. HAVE TO
SHOOT IT BECAUSE T TT OUT IN FR.
THAT ONE WILL COUNT AFTER MARCU
MADE IT  DOWN LOW.
THROWS IT OUT IN